nueva y devastadora temporada de
incendios en el hemisferio norte donde
cada verano la emergencia climática es
más visible alrededor del planeta los
récords de altas temperaturas la sequía
y el viento dificultan el control del
fuego en california el incendio dixie ha
obligado a evacuar hasta 10.000
viviendas
muy intenso podías ver el color rojo
bajando por las montañas las llamas del
fuego
es muy intenso realmente es un monstruo
del otro lado del estrecho de bering en
rusia las llamas arrasan la región de
yakuta la comunidad científica alerta
que el humo de los incendios provoca la
fusión del permafrost de la tundra
siberiana proceso que libera todavía más
co2 a la atmósfera y que acelera el
deshielo del polo norte frente a la
impotencia de los equipos de emergencia
el fuego sigue descontrolado oinez
porque en algunas regiones apagar el
fuego es complicado porque el humo llega
hasta los aeropuertos no podemos usar
los tanques de agua aéreos en el sur de
europa las llamas se expanden por el
mediterráneo' arde españa italia albania
macedonia del norte turquía y grecia
donde el fuego en la zona de la capital
atenas y ha causado víctimas mortales en
el promedio
catastrófico es un de esa posible el
fuego llega hasta el lago no puedan
pasear por allí jamás es una tragedia
liotti inimaginable el dejo menos
tradición con ambos hasta por eso
tragedias inimaginables que la inacción
frente al cambio climático ha convertido
ya en habituales